i just finished my phd at the university
of cambridge on quantum computing
and it was a great experience that i
don't regret at all
and yet i still wouldn't recommend a phd
to many people
this video is about why and what pieces
of advice i would give if you are
thinking about doing a phd
they are do something else first look
for the right things in a supervisor
choose a university with a lot happening
and finally
if you want to do a phd in the us please
please consider some other options
as well a big caveat before i start
though
this is entirely my own opinion and bias
towards what i know which is the uk
system
i hope it's still useful for you though
so let's get started
if you're in university and you're
thinking about doing a phd
then let me guess you've probably got
good grades and you really like studying
you might also not really know what else
to do with yourself if you were to just
leave the university system and go into
the wild
the simplest option might seem to be to
do what's next on the path
a masters or a phd a phd though
is something that you'll hate unless you
love it it's super common for people to
drop out of phd programs and i think it
happens because
a lot of people realize that this wasn't
something that they really cared about
much after all
they were just doing it because they
thought that there was nothing
interesting
outside of academia instead of assuming
that try and get a job
and see whether you really do hate it if
you do then after a year you can always
go back
i was sure that i wanted to do a phd but
i still really benefited from taking a
break
that break helped me decide what i
wanted to research
often the topics that people end up
doing research in
are the ones that they stumbled on in
undergrad research or
are in subjects that they liked at
university i really liked functional
analysis classes in undergrad so
naturally i thought i'd study that but
in my time off
on the side of doing some teaching gigs
i started exploring bits of physics i
liked and following up on things that i
was curious about
i got really into quantum foundations
and i knew that that's what i wanted to
do my research on
if you do take a break though it will be
harder to go straight into a competitive
phd program
but in some countries you pretty much
have to do a one to two year masters
first
so take that break between undergrad and
that masters
it's quite easy to get into a master's
even after a significant break
don't worry about doing a competitive
masters though just do one at a local
university and get
amazing grades that will make you a much
stronger phd candidate
if you're still worried about taking a
full-on break because it'll look bad or
because you're dead set on a phd
that's okay you should still take a
break though to do some research before
the phd
research feels nothing like studying
when you're studying you're supposed to
just accept and memorize everything you
learn
research though is about questioning
things and no one is there to pat you on
the head
you need to be curious and you need to
be willing to explore all on your own
so see if that's the kind of thing you'd
enjoy before you step into a phd
you can do this by doing research over a
summer or a research assistant role
or a research masters for a year to see
if you really enjoy that sort of thing
i got lucky because i mostly had an
awesome time during my phd
but that's not the typical experience a
lot of people run into politics with
their group or feel completely neglected
by their supervisor and this can be
crushing
here's my advice then check that your
supervisor is supportive and friendly
try and meet up with them before you
sign up and see if you get on
also ask their former students what it
was like working with them
make sure that the group you join also
has a culture of collaborating both
internally and with other groups
that's important because at the start
you'll know nothing you'll learn by
doing projects with others
again this is something that you can
gauge from students in the group
it's good to meet up with them and see
if they seem interesting
these are probably the people that
you'll be talking to the most in the
coming years
and finally look out for a supervisor
whose work you really
admire remember you're likely to work on
similar topics so there is no point
finding someone who is say
famous but works on something you're not
into and there's also no point finding
someone who's in the right field but
does low quality work
[Music]
i think it's super important to go to a
university where you can get involved
with lots of extracurriculars
that's because a lot of the value you'll
get out of this degree comes from the
stuff you'll be doing on the side
consider the fact that phds are usually
three to eight years
of the prime of your life other people
will have a couple of jobs in that time
maybe settle down start a family and if
you're going to be spending those years
depressed in a windowless lab instead
you're missing out what's more if you're
making that sacrifice because you think
you'll get rewarded
know that you probably won't the vast
majority of phd students
don't become academics even though a phd
is specifically designed to make you one
that means you can spend ages honing
very particular skills that you won't
really use
the general research skills are great
and i do think that i became a sharper
thinker
but maybe you'd learn just as many
valuable skills on a relevant job
i don't know however what a phd is
really good for is that it gives you a
huge amount of freedom to research
something that you're really interested
in
and freedom to explore other hobbies as
well so
if you're sure you want to do a phd then
make sure you're learning things that
will be valuable to you later
your university can expose you to so
many opportunities and that's why you
should pick one that's well known
for active student clubs or public
lectures or in a city with lots of other
fun things going on
depending on what kind of phd you do the
workload can be less and way more
flexible
than if you were doing a job at the same
time you have so many interesting people
doing interesting things around you who
you can start side projects with
i think that you should take learning
things from those extracurricular
activities
very seriously because you're hardly
going to have an opportunity like this
again
i don't think i did this as well as i
could have but i was conscious of it so
i did make something of an effort
but i think you can do better if you
really tried here's a list of some of
the things that i did to give you a
sense of what's possible though
i joined a science outreach group that
toured the uk to show science
experiments to kids over summer i got
really into
effective altruism i ran off to teach in
china for three weeks
i attended conferences all over the
world i was on the rowing team for a
term
even though i'm extremely small i went
to a lot of public lectures
i gave a public lecture i'd travel to
london a lot to watch people do stand-up
comedy
and probably the highlight the festival
of the spoken nerd people
accidentally let me do a stand-up comedy
set
in front of 500 people anyway
now my supervisor knows just how often i
was away from the office
but yeah i don't regret any of it i got
to explore a lot and realize just how
much i love teaching and performing
so even though i enjoyed the research a
ton and i always thought that i'd be an
academic
i decided to go into science
communication full-time instead
okay here we go this is the
controversial one but let me put this to
you
in australia the uk mainland europe and
many other places
a phd is meant to take three years a lot
of people take longer so let's say four
years
in the us a phd is at least five years
though
and depending on the subject the average
can be seven years
or more maybe a us phd is right for you
but i'd just like you to consider the
options before you commit
that many years of your life to
something you might be wondering how the
non-us system can be that much shorter
that's partly explained by the fact that
it's normal to do
a masters before a phd in places like
the uk
but you're still looking at at least two
years less time in total which
isn't huge but it's not nothing a nice
thing about the uk system in my opinion
is that it gives you a lot of points at
which you can stop and reflect on
whether this is the right path for you
plus in the us it seems like the phd
part can really drag out
another thing to consider us phd's at
least
from my perspective as an outsider seem
grueling
i've seen phd students in australia and
in the uk
and people work very normal hours and
don't work on weekends much
and go on plenty of holidays the
stereotype for us
students though and u.s academics in
general
is that they just work super super hard
if you're going to do that then you'll
have
much less time for your own things
remember wherever you do the phd those
years of commitment
may never pay off if what you're looking
for is a 10-year job in academia
the vast vast majority of people who do
a phd
don't become academics less than 10
and what's more the goal may not be
worth it in the first place
tenured profs are often so bogged down
with admin teaching and supervising that
research is relegated and what's even
more scary for me
is the lifestyle between doing a phd and
getting tenure
here's where you'll be doing postdocs
these are two to three year contract
jobs that you'll typically have to move
around a bunch for
in my field in europe it's pretty normal
to do three
three-year post-docs that would mean
that you'd need to move a whole lot of
times between the ages of
30 and 40. even though the prospect of
landing a full-time job from
this effort is still low i don't know
too much about it but
apparently in the u.s job security for
academics is also pretty terrible
that's because universities hire many
more casually employed adjuncts these
days
instead of full-time teaching staff that
means that even after committing
yourself to the field until your middle
age
you might have no job security and be
paid terribly
these are all things to consider if
you're going into a phd with the hope of
one day becoming a professor
i hope that wasn't too depressing
because like i said i ultimately
really loved doing a phd the experience
can be a great springboard into other
things
but trying for a life in academia just
didn't seem worth it to me
however that's just what i think i
really recommend you hear other people's
opinions too
if you're thinking about this i've made
a playlist to get you started below
good luck whatever you choose